how do we get from this to this that is
switching the form factor of our pod POI
from these kind of teardrop shapes to
being the more spherical contact POI
that we all know and love well I'm going
to help you out with that today
[Music]
thank you Drex here from drexfactor boy
sharing with you the love of poi
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain and today we're going to
be talking about a relatively simple
conversion that you can do at home that
might get you a little bit more life out
of your LED POI but before we dive in I
want to give a quick shout out to the
Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyroterra light
toys spin balls and Ultra POI for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all of these awesome companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I have down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non-business Friends of
the channel Lane machinski and Becca
beklonen thank you both so much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission so I don't really know if this
is common knowledge out there or not but
there's actually a pretty easy way that
you can convert your pod POI which are
among the most popular LED POI they're
out on the market and be able to stick
them inside of these spherical contact
poi balls and thus convert them
essentially into contact POI which I
think are the most popular form factor
for POI out there right now so why might
you want to do a thing like that well I
can think of a few reasons off the top
of my head now there are already several
options out there for Led contact POI
but one of those things that the
capsules inside of pod POI really have
going for them is that they're really
really comprehensive in terms of how you
can program them now that flowtoys has a
smartphone app out there that allows you
to help navigate the modes as well as
create your own custom programs that
means that the capsules offer one of the
most comprehensive programming options
out there and being able to have a set
of contact POI that can do that is
really a big bonus in addition you might
have picked up pod POI earlier in your
flow journey and found that you just
like all those contact tricks just so
incredibly much maybe you want to get a
set of contact boy but you don't want to
plunk down the entire amount of money it
would take to get a new set of LED
contact POI so the conversion actually
is a cheaper way to get there or perhaps
you're just a tinkerer and like taking
on projects like this honestly there's
no wrong reason for doing this and just
to State the obvious yes you can
purchase sets of poi from flow toys that
already have the Emoji spheres on them
they're called their flow Mojo POI but
some people just start off with pod POI
and want to make the conversion at some
point so I figured I would guide them
through how to do it and this actually
personally came up for me recently
because I'm working on a POI dance piece
that required a lot of pretty intense
programming of the LED POI and honestly
I just found that capsules were the best
fit for it but at the same time I'd
already choreographed some contact rules
into it so I needed the contact form
factor Best of Both Worlds to be found
right here cool so we are going to cover
both how to make the conversion happen
with the classic pod POI that have the
Smithy rope tethers as well as the newer
FPC tether pod POI because the
techniques are just slightly different
between the two of them I'll go ahead
and include links to the time stamps for
each different one down below if you
want to skip to that part of the video
regardless of which set you intend to
convert you're going to need two things
the first is going to be a set of pod
POI from flowtoys and the second is
going to be a set of emojispheres from
Lantern Smith I do have promo codes with
both companies so you can get a discount
on your order you can use the code
drexfactor 2023 with a 3 instead of an e
and a zero instead of an O at checkout
over at flowtoys.com and you can use the
code directs factor with a zero instead
of an O over at Lantern Smith both of
those codes get you discounts on those
companies products and just to put this
out there if you're doing the conversion
the other way around that is you have a
set of emoji POI from Lantern Smith and
you want to add LEDs to them I would
recommend purchasing both a set of
capsules from flowtoys as well as a set
of their tethers and handles the reason
being that flow toys does something
special with the ends of their tethers
to make them fit inside of the ends of
the capsules that land Smith POI do not
do by default and are kind of a pain in
the butt to set up yourself so I would
just get the tethers from flow toys if
you could and I hope you will pardon my
very scuffed up emoji sphere here
because it is very well loved at this
point all right so let's start this off
by converting a set of classic pod POI
with Smithy rope and adding a set of
emoji spheres to them all right so the
first thing you're going to want to do
is you're going to want to remove this
retaining ring that is on the end of the
shell around the capsule you're going to
do that by pulling upwards on one of
these ends of the retaining ring and
that's going to allow you to slide it
off completely of that silicone shell
you're going to slide it down we're
going to come back to that in just a
second here the next thing you're going
to want to do is you're going to want to
get the capsule outside of the shell
here's how that happens you're going to
want to grip the capsule reaching inside
the petals here and you're going to want
to find a place where you can add a
little bit of pressure out here on the
bottom of the shell next to the button
and you're going to push until you can
and get the capsule free
sometimes you'll wind up having it pull
off this little retaining ring right
here sometimes the retaining ring stays
on we're going to be removing it in a
second anyway so if it falls off that's
totally fine but you should wind up now
with an empty shell and you can go ahead
and set that aside for the time being
our next step is that we're going to go
ahead and remove this plastic retaining
ring from the side of the capsule that
has the button on it how you do that is
you're going to go ahead and find this
little spot here where there's a gap
because it's not a continuous ring and
you're going to pull just a little bit
on that until it comes loose and then
the rest of the Ring should come loose
as well
once again set that aside for right now
our next move is to remove this little
rubber band that we have here on the
opposite end of the capsule that is the
end that has the tether coming out of it
so we're going to go ahead and just slip
our finger a little bit under that
rubber band to start rolling it off the
end of the capsule and now we can remove
the capsule from the tether we're going
to reattach the two in a second but for
right now we want to detach it so open
up the capsule just enough to be able to
remove the end of the tether and
keep those two sides of the capsule
together you're not going to want to
lose those
now we're going to want to remove both
the retaining ring as well as the rubber
band please note there's a washer here
usually on the other end of the tether
we are not removing that we're only
removing first this little rubber band
again put that aside and next we are
removing this three-pronged retaining
ring this might take a little bit of
jimmying to get it through here because
sometimes the washer is a size that is
just slightly bigger than the retaining
ring but it should come relatively
easily now you can set that aside our
next step is to take the emojisphere now
please note all emojispheres have both a
narrow side and this is usually the side
that has the words Lantern Smith and
emoja 90 millimeter on it and the other
end which is wider and has no text on it
we want to take the end of the tether
that is the one that has that washer on
it or the flat end and we want to poke
it through the narrow end of the
emojisphere that is the one that has the
text on it we want to thread it all the
way through and out to the other side
now we want to go ahead and take our
capsule and go ahead and open up the end
of that capsule that is the one that
doesn't have the button on it and you're
going to insert the end of the tether
into it and snap the two ends back
together you want to make sure that it's
pretty snug and the end of the tether is
not coming back out
from here you want to go ahead and push
the capsule back through the Emojis
sphere it'll go most of the way without
much resistance but then you'll hit a
point where you do feel some resistance
and that's okay what we're going to do
now is we're going to take our thumbs
and push the end that has the button
attached to it so that we get the other
end to come out through the other side
of the Emoji sphere so we should have
just a little bit of the capsule showing
off of the side of the Emoji sphere that
has the text on it this is the end that
has the tether and now we have completed
our first
conversion to a set of contact POI here
you'll note that the button for the
capsule rests just inside of the top of
the sphere here so it's not likely to
accidentally get pushed and we now have
this little end of the capsule sticking
out on the other side and yes that is
kind of baked in there is no way to get
rid of that cool so so now you've got
one contact POI and you want to perform
the exact same operation with your other
pod POI one thing I recommend doing
after you've completed each conversion
is taking the rubber band the plastic
ring and the retaining ring and actually
storing them inside of the empty shell
so you have all the parts together if
you ever want to convert your set of pod
POI back which there's a variety of
reasons that you might want to and this
just makes it a lot more convenient to
have all the pieces ready when that
happens all right cool so now let's talk
about how to do the conversion from a
set of FPC pod POI that is the Pod POI
with the thicker FPC tethers and
sticking the Emoji spheres on those so
this is actually going to be super
similar to how we converted the set with
Smithy rope you're going to start off by
looking for this plastic retaining ring
that is going to be on the end of the
shell that is closest to the tether
you're going to want to go ahead and
stick your finger underneath one of
these prongs on it and that is going to
help give you enough leverage to get get
that retaining ring off completely go
ahead and slide that down the tether
we're going to come back to that in a
second next we're again going to grab
onto the capsule with one hand and we're
going to look for a place where we can
apply a little bit of pressure here on
the over on the other side of the shell
I'm also sticking a thumb inside of the
shell to help move it and push the shell
completely off of the capsule put the
shell aside for right now now this is
going to look really really similar to
the setup from the Smithy rope set of
pod POI with one crucial difference
there's another plastic retaining ring
on the other side of the POI but we're
we'll deal with that in just a second
to remove this first retaining ring that
is the one that is right next to the
button here I'm going to go ahead and
once again stick my thumb right next to
one side of the retaining ring where
there's the Gap here and I'm going to
use that leverage to go ahead and pull
the retaining ring off completely you
don't need to put too much pressure on
this it just takes a little bit you're
going to set aside that retaining ring
and now we're going to do the same thing
on the other side of the capsule I'm
going to look for that Gap in the
retaining ring here and I'm going to go
ahead and stick my thumb right on the
edge of it and apply just a little bit
of pressure to get the retaining ring to
separate and then I can pull it off of
the capsule completely
once again we're going to go ahead and
open up the capsule really really gently
here and I'm going to go ahead and
remove the tether from the end of the
capsule let's keep those two ends of the
capsule together they're going to be
important
next we go ahead and take the retaining
ring and take it off of the tether
and then the other retaining ring and
take it off of the end of the tether
they should both slide off pretty easily
and now we go ahead and take our
emojisphere and remember the end that we
want to put onto the tether is the one
that is more narrow it has the text
around it we go ahead and push the end
of the tether
through that end of the Emoji sphere
that has the text on it we thread it all
the way through and when it comes out
the other side we go ahead and we take
our capsule
we want to go ahead and just gingerly
open the side of the capsule that has
the opening in it not the button but the
opening just slightly and we want to
insert the end of the tether inside of
it now please note you want to stick the
end of the tether as far as it'll go in
here it's actually going to touch the
end of the battery we then go ahead and
close up the end of the capsule it
should once again be pretty snug here
and we want to go ahead and thread the
tether back through the Emoji sphere and
when we encounter resistance we want to
go ahead and stick our thumbs on either
side of the button end of the capsule
and we want to go ahead and push
the capsule all the way through so we
get the entirety of this end of the
capsule through you'll note that there
is basically a little Ridge and then a
dip on this end of the capsule you want
to push it so far through that the dip
has come completely through the end of
the emojisphere and
there we go we now have one POI
completed next you want to do the next
one and just like we did with the Smithy
rope pod POI you want to go ahead and
take all the hardware that you took out
of the shell and go ahead and store it
with the shell to make sure it doesn't
get lost and again that way you can make
the conversion back anytime you want
awesome so let's see those new flow Mojo
POI rips shall we
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
I'd love to see the results please post
photographs or video to Instagram and
tag me I am at drexfactor on the
platform and I would love to see the
results of your hard work did you get
anything out of this video please make
sure to like share comment and subscribe
to help other people find it and to help
my channel grow
[Music]
thank you
this video would not be possible where
not for the kind support of all of these
lovely people right here these are my
flow patrons over on patreon they and
the people listed down in the
description help to make this video and
all the videos on this channel possible
thank you one and all so very much for
your very generous support and if you
out there watching are not currently a
supporter but you'd like to become one
you can do that by heading on over to
patreon.com
drexfactor POI you can do that at the
link down in the description or the card
that just popped up if you are watching
on YouTube there you can get access to a
whole host of awesome rewards and even
better than that you'll be helping me
out in my mission to bring POI spinning
and flow yards to the whole wide world
so go check that out please and thank
you and if you'd like to check out more
of my videos on POI equipment including
reviews I will go ahead and leave a link
to a playlist of those videos down in
the description as well as up here on
screen if you are watching on YouTube
also the YouTube algorithm thinks that
you might like this top video here
because it's popular amongst viewers on
my channel so maybe give that a look as
well thank you so much for watching make
sure to get out and flow today and I'll
see you with a new video real soon
peace